الى مشهد الاحتجاجات المتصاعد في فرنسا
بعد اعلان الرئاسات الفرنسيه اقرار الرئيس
منو الماكرون مشروع قانون اصلاح التقاعد
دون تصويت برلمانيه اعتمادا على ماده
دستوريه هذه الاحتجاجات المستمره والتي
نشاهد صورها مباشره على الهواء في العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس واضح انها احتجاجات
تشتد
وتييرتها في هذا المساء كما تظهر هذه
الصور وقد دعى الرئيس ماكرون دعا رئيسه
الحكومه الاجتماع قبل بدء جلسه لمجلس
النواب للتصويت على مشروع قانون التقاعد
مساء اليوم وقبل التصويت عبرت مصادر قريبه
من الحكومه عن خشيتها من عدم تامين اغلبيه
داخل مجلس النواب لتمرير مشروع القانون
كان مجلس الشيوخ قد صدق صباح اليوم على نص
مشروع قانون التقاعد باغلبيه
193 عضوا مقابل اعتراض
واربعه عشر وقد تبنى مجلس الشيوخ النسخه
نفسها التي اعتمدت اللجنه البرلمانيه
المشتركه متساويه الاعضاء بين مجلسي
الشيوخ والنواب يوم امس الاربعاء
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بك سيد ستيفان هذه الصور التي
نتابعها مباشره
احتجاجات متصاعده مستمره واضح ان
اقرار القانون
بتوقيع الرئيس
لم يهدئوا بالاحرى لم يضع حدا للمشكله
ويبدو ان الشارع اكثر تصاعدا في احتجاجاته
الى اين تسير الامور في في فرنسا
والاحتماليه ايضا كما قلت طرح الثقه
بالحكومه واسقاط
واسقاط الحكومه هل يفضل الرئيس مكروه ان
تسقط الحكومه
مقابل ان يضع توقيعه على هذا القانون
ويتجنب الجمعيه الوطنيه
المخاطره كبيره وهذا الواقع الدليل على
ضعفه فهو معزول في حياه السياسيه الفرنسيه
اليوم وهو قيامه بذلك يدل على لا يتمتع
بغالبيه في الجمعيه الوطنيه
وحتى
اليمين اذا هو قام بحسابات
بانه غالبيه النواب لن يجتمعوا
لاسقاط الحكومه ورئيسه الوزراء بورنو وهذا
احتمال ربما سيتصل في ذلك وعندما النقشه
مع المحللين هو بامكانه ان يمنع استقاله
ببضعه اصوات من النواب لكن مهما كانت
نتيجه هذا هذا اقتراح لحجب الثقه عن رئيسه
الوزراء والحكومه فلذلك حتى لو كان تجري
ليس لصالحه هو فهذا على ضعف الرئيس
وبالتالي انه لديه خوف فهو طبعا كان من
افضل ان يسحبها مشروع القانون هذا
والفرنسيون وبشكل المتزايد يشعرون بعداء
ارتياح للرئيس ماكرون مهما كانت نتيجه
التصويت فان علاقه الرئيس ماكرون مع
المواطنين الفرنسيين ستتفرر وتتاثر وتؤثر
على حياته السياسيه
الاشهر السنوات القادمه فما زالت لديه مده
اربع سنوات الحكم وهذا سيعقد بعمله في
السلطه
في باريس مدير قسم السياسه والابحاث في
معهد ابسوس شكرا جزيلا لك